[Music]
our main story tonight concerns taiwan
and it's honestly remarkable that we
haven't talked about taiwan before in
this show given it's the birthplace of
bubble tea which is delicious even
though tapioca ball sounds like a sex
move for people over 70. and especially
since taiwan shares our unhealthy
obsession with mascots cities there make
tons of them there is this one the
milkfish kids celebrating one area's
milkfish production and there is this
one from a region that produces bananas
which i do not want to talk about right
now
in fact taiwan makes so many mascots
that in some cities the very act of
storing them has become a problem
we went with the city councillor to a
taipei public school following her into
the depths of a basement parking lot
here behind a door we discovered a
mountain of abandoned mascots
this is sacred fire baby from 2013
national games held in taipei
the city government should really think
about whether it's necessary to keep
creating one off mascots oh come on
taiwan you can't just keep making
mascots and throwing them away
thankfully at the end of our seasons our
mascots go to live on a beautiful farm a
fantastic green farm where jeff the
diseased lung can breathe fresh air and
the polar bear with a broken penis can
get the care he so badly needs i keep
asking my producer where this farm is
she keeps telling me i'll tell you when
you're older i can't wait
but obviously the major reason that
taiwan ends up in the news these days is
because of its relationship with china
which to put it mildly is fraught and
recently it's getting even fraughter
china has long viewed taiwan as its own
national territory china's president xi
jinping on saturday all but declaring it
policy
the complete reunification of our
country must be and will be realized he
said military tensions between the two
sides are soaring china's air force sent
nearly 150 planes into taiwan's air
defense zone since the start of this
month yeah they did not exactly like
that i presume in a big stack i'm
guessing they flew the planes out one at
a time not heaped on top of each other
like an air traffic controller's
nightmare
the point is china insists that taiwan
an independently operating entity with
its own democratically elected leaders
armed forces and constitution is
actually part of china and in no way a
separate country here's an
understatement the chinese government
feels strongly about this so strongly in
fact that when john cena went on a press
stall for the most recent fast and
furious movie and said taiwan is the
first country that can watch f9 this is
what happened next actor john cena has
apologized to china after
[Music]
uh
every part of that is so weird
it's weird john cena apologized to china
it's where he did it for calling taiwan
a country and it's weird to see him do
it in pretty decent mandarin
that's just too many weird things a half
expected that shot to pan out to reveal
he's also doing a needlepoint of liam
neeson kissing an ostrich honestly it
would only make it slightly stranger but
john cena is not alone here taiwan is
such a third rail for china that it may
be why paramount pictures removed the
taiwanese flag from tom cruise's jacket
for the top gun sequel and it is
definitely why the gap apologized for
releasing this t-shirt featuring a map
of china without taiwan attached that
shirt caused a storm and it led to
the gap makers of the bland t-shirts
that dads wear were when they're on the
elliptical for 30 minutes to apologize
to 1.4 billion people so if china is
getting t-shirt retractions from the gap
loudly vowing to reunify with taiwan and
sending stacks of warplanes towards it
in record-breaking numbers it feels like
tonight it'd be worth taking a look at
taiwan how it got to be in the unique
position that it's in what the world
wants from it and most importantly what
it wants for itself and let's start with
how we got here historically taiwan has
been like the stanley cup of asian
history and that different people keep
passing it around and carving their
names on it
here is a ludicrously brief history of
the last four hundred years there taiwan
or is it sometimes been called formosa
it was first home to indigenous people
then colonized by the dutch and briefly
the spanish before china's qing dynasty
held it for about 200 years then in 1895
china lost taiwan to japan which turned
it was so-called model colony imposing
japanese cultural values and generally
ruling it with an iron fist then after
world war ii two major things happened
first the allies put taiwan back under
chinese control and second the civil war
that was taking place in china between
the nationalist government led by chiang
kai-shek and the communists led by mao
zedong ended now spoiler alert the
communists won
congratulations to mao
and in the wake of that defeat chiang
kai-shek fled to taiwan along with two
million nationalist soldiers and
refugees basically setting up a chinese
government in exile meaning that china
technically had two governments at the
time one in china and one in taiwan and
western countries were very invested in
the success of the second one even
calling taiwan free china because they
saw it as a necessary bulwark against
communism
against all prophecies formosa still
keeps the anti-communist flag flying
only 100 miles or so off the mainland of
china
it's a prosperous island where the new
generations grow up in freedom a
complete contrast to conditions under
the rule of mao tatum you know i do kind
of miss that period of human history
where the only way to learn about other
cultures was to have a british man on
amphetamine to tell you which were the
good ones and which were the baddies
here we see formosans living in freedom
well not freedom per se but the point is
they're not commies and that's where my
curiosity terminates
but well jan kaishek might have been a
staunchly anti-communist u.s ally
historically we've had a lot of those
and they often haven't been great people
and chang ruled taiwan as a brutal
authoritarian thousands were swept up in
a period that came to be known as the
white terror suffering imprisonment
torture and even execution doing
anything that could be remotely
construed as criticism of the government
was extremely risky as one writer
discovered when he merely translated a
popeye
popeye and his son were in exile on an
island and they were campaigning for
election there
yet
popeye gave a speech and he used an
english word fellows
there could be hundreds of translations
for fellows but i chose one which was
all my fellow countrymen
this was terrible the bureau of
investigation arrested me saying why
didn't you translate it into something
else this is exactly the way our
president john speaks
you are making fun of him it deserves
the death penalty no doubt the death
penalty it's true that guy was
interrogated for months on suspicion of
being a communist collaborator and
ultimately spent nine years in prison
all because zhang's government thought a
popeye comic had a hidden political
message which is a bit of a reach there
is clearly no deeper meaning to popeye
comics other than women are inherently
prizes to be fought over
performance-enhancing drugs are cool and
pluto doesn't deserve love all of which
is to say in the middle of the last
century taiwan was a grim place but
after chung died in 1975 under pressure
both internationally and from political
movements at home the nationalists began
to loosen their grip ending martial law
in the late 80s and opening the door to
full democratization so against the odds
taiwan shifted from a dictatorship to a
functioning vibrant democracy and i do
mean vibrant
a debate over how billions of euros will
be allocated for an infrastructure
development plan descended into a brawl
in taiwan's parliament on tuesday
members of the ruling democratic
progressive party and the opposition
nationalist party threw water and shoved
each other to the floor
taiwan's mps are known for brawling and
even throwing objects at each other and
fights in parliament are even seen as
one way for the opposition to show
voters that it stands tough on issues
yeah
fighting is not uncommon in taiwan's
parliament here they are throwing water
balloons at each other and here they are
hurling pig guts during a debate on pork
imports and that is not all one time in
2006 a member snatched a written
proposal of a bill and shoved it into
her own mouth which is fantastic and
definitely something that we should
steal you want to kill a clean energy
bill pull up a chair and eat all
900 pages of it
but taiwan is not just a functioning
democracy it's a major player in the
global supply chain taiwan was the
fastest growing economy in asia last
year and it's the world's key
manufacturer of semiconductors which are
used absolutely everywhere in products
from cars to sex toys so the next time
that you fire up a butt plug that has a
hundred thousand times more computing
power than the apollo moon mission make
sure you say thanks taiwan
so all of this brings us to where we are
right now with taiwan established as a
highly developed and wealthy country and
yet
no one is allowed to call it one and
that brings us back to the huge
unresolved issue of taiwanese
sovereignty because china now sees
claiming taiwan as a key point of
national pride with xi jinping calling
reunification part of his vision for the
great rejuvenation of the chinese nation
and anyone wanting to do business in
china knows that calling taiwan a
country is a massive faux pas and it's
not just the gap and john cena who have
found this out all of these companies
have either had to apologize for or walk
back even the smallest implication that
taiwan is a separate country and you can
see this caution everywhere at this
year's olympics you probably saw
taiwanese athletes competing not under
the taiwanese flag but under the fake
pseudo flag of chinese taipei something
they've been forced to use at every
olympic since the 1980s when they
reached a compromise with the ioc that
allowed them to participate without
angering china but this arrangement
isn't something that all taiwanese
people appreciate in fact during the
2012 games the lead singer of taiwanese
heavy metal band bandhonic pointed out
just how ludicrous it is
our team our national team being called
chinese taipei
right oh we can't call
you taiwan sorry we have to call you
chinese taipei
look
i know i say this every week but that
death metal singer complaining about
olympic nomenclature has a real point
there although
although to be fair if their official
olympics name really was chinese
taipei
that would at least be a little more
accurate vis-a-vis who is whom
and even huge international
organizations like the who are forced to
play this ridiculous game freezing out
taiwan from full participation last year
when one who official was pressed on
this point by a hong kong newscaster it
led to this very awkward interaction
would the who consider taiwan's
membership
[Laughter]
hello
i couldn't hear your question okay yeah
let me let me let me repeat the question
no that's okay let's move to another one
then right because because i'm actually
curious on talking about taiwan as well
on taiwan's case
we decided to give dr alward another
call to follow up
and i just want to see if you can
comment a bit on how taiwan has done so
far in terms of containing the virus
well we've already talked about china
oh
we did did we are you sure about that
because it sure seems like first you
pretended not to hear the question then
fakes getting disconnected after
committing the world's most telegraphed
log off
that man couldn't be more clearly
avoiding the question if he came back
online pretending to be a lamp uh you
can't ask a lamp about taiwan especially
me i only speak french so that's
actually two reasons i shouldn't have to
answer this question i'm a lamp and i
only speak french except for this brief
paragraph in english explaining my
situation au revoir
but it is not just companies and
international organizations the vast
majority of world governments have no
official diplomatic relations with
taiwan because china won't have
diplomatic relations with anyone who
does and for all the initial
cheerleading from western countries
about taiwan's pluck and verve in
keeping the anti-communist fleet flying
things have shifted by the end of the
1970s most countries had switched their
recognition of china's official
government from the one on taiwan known
as the republic of china to the
communist one on the mainland the
people's republic of china in fact today
the number of governments still willing
to diplomatically recognize taiwan has
joined us to only 14 countries and the
holy see although that last one really
shouldn't be that surprising to you you
know the pope he loves to stir up
drinks wine in the morning he's a messy
who lives for drama
now
as for america we've spent the past half
century walking a diplomatic tightrope
with a policy known as strategic
ambiguity it's something that lets us
maintain functional relations with
taiwan and still have a full formal
relationship with china it's an approach
that began in the 1970s and it was built
upon a series of incredibly carefully
worded statements
the united states
in one of our communiques with the
people's republic of china
acknowledged the prc position that
taiwan was part of china but the united
states also did not accept the prc claim
to taiwan that has been our position
ever since and so in effect
the us
views taiwan's status as undetermined
right we acknowledged china's claim but
didn't agree with it leaving taiwan's
status as undetermined you know like
schrodinger's cat or the scientology
version miscavige his wife there could
be one thing or the other thing and no
one knows for sure do they david hey
david david
where's shelley
but that confusion is emblematic of the
strategic ambiguity policy for instance
the us operates out of this building in
taiwan often referred to as its de facto
embassy but not crucially as an actual
embassy taiwan meanwhile has this
building in dc which does pretty much
everything that an embassy would do just
without actually being called one and i
know that this policy can occasionally
seem ridiculous but the uncertainty is
kind of the point especially when it
comes to defence in 1979 congress passed
the taiwan relations act in which the
u.s committed to assist taiwan in
maintaining its self-defense capability
but that commitment very much stopped
short of the u.s promising to defend
taiwan from a chinese invasion instead
it says any effort to determine the
future of taiwan by other than peaceful
means would be of grave concern to the
united states and what does that even
mean does it mean the us would deploy
military assets or just that the us
general would slightly raise an eyebrow
no one really knows it is a willfully
confusing will they or won't they dance
that for 40 years has been the backbone
of u.s taiwan policy and look
so far we've been talking about taiwan
almost exclusively in terms of what
other countries want from it but the key
question is clearly what does it want
for itself but even that is not easy to
answer taiwan is made up of a mix of
different cultures languages and
political viewpoints remember that
lawmakers sometimes throw pig intestines
at each other in parliament everyone is
not on the same page there
but to the extent taranis people have
spoken through the ballot box they've
chosen a government that wants to keep
china at arm's length that singer that
you saw earlier talking about chinese
taipei he's actually in taiwan's
parliament now and he is openly
pro-independence as for taiwan's current
leader cy ing wen she was elected on a
platform of defending taiwan but
crucially
preserving the status quo just watch how
cautiously she discusses the question of
taiwanese independence
are you in principle at least in favor
of the idea of formal taiwanese
independence
the reality and what it is now is that
we are already a functionally
independent country and we have our own
government and we have our own election
will there come a day when that reality
needs to be spelled out by a formal
declaration of independence the idea is
we don't have a need to declare
ourselves an independent statement we
are an independent country
right she's clearly declaring that
they're independent there but also very
much drawing the line at a declaration
of independence because she knows that
taiwan explicitly formalizing the way
things are could cause a lot of trouble
it's like meeting your partner's parents
for the first time and saying hello i
regularly your offspring yeah
everyone was aware of that but now that
you've officially declared it things are
going to get much more difficult for
everyone involved here
and the truth is that intense pragmatism
is in line with how many taiwanese
people feel polls have consistently
shown that when they are asked about
independence from or unification with
china something like one and a half
percent want unification with china as
soon as possible and about six percent
want independence as soon as possible
but the vast majority favor some version
of sticking with the status quo at least
four now which does make sense because
as things stand as volatile as this
situation can appear day-to-day life in
taiwan can go on as normal as this
taiwanese man shows
up
[Music]
wow that is a pretty relaxed attitude
given the circumstances here he's
talking about the nuclear-armed
saber-rattling superpower taunting his
country with warplanes like it's season
two of emily in paris you know i don't
love that it's happening but honestly i
just tried to carry on with my life
but the question is can the currently
safe status quo hold forever xi xingping
has stated that the question of taiwan
cannot simply be passed on from
generation to generation and those
military drills do seem to be sending a
message and while experts say war is not
imminent taiwan is understandably
thinking about its own defense
capabilities something by the way that
the us has been happy to assist them in
thinking about by selling them billions
of dollars in weapons showing that even
strategic ambiguity has its price
but despite u.s assistance the taiwan
military is obviously a fraction of
china's and its recent attempts to atta
attract recruits have left something to
be desired
the armed forces have been producing
videos like this to try to drum up
enthusiasm among potential young
soldiers
but they've been struggling to make up
for a shortfall left by a phasing out of
conscription
okay i am really not sure that that is
helping that does not look like a group
of people who are excited to be in the
military it looks like a bunch of
background dancers who were cut from in
the heights because they were too boring
to be on camera
so what exactly can or should be done
here well that is something that the
entire world has been dissecting for
half a century now and so far the answer
we seem to have settled on is some
version of uh
next question please
which is clearly not very satisfying and
i know ambiguity is inherently
frustrating especially for americans who
might look at a place like taiwan which
looks and acts like a country and feel
that it is weird and farcical to not
acknowledge it as one but from a
practical standpoint would that be
better and is that even what the people
of taiwan want could it be that
maintaining the current deeply weird
ambiguous status quo is actually the
best option here
i don't know i'm not taiwanese and
frankly people who aren't taiwanese
making decisions for taiwan is a bit
played out historically
so maybe the best thing that we can do
is move past talking about taiwan like
it's some kind of poker chip in a
never-ending game of us versus them
because the fact is taiwan is not a
plucky bulwark against the red menace
nor is it some sort of island-sized
viagra to rejuvenate the chinese nation
taiwan is 23 million people who in the
face of considerable odds have built a
free democratic society and very much
deserve the right to decide their own
future in any way that they deem fit
even if that means sporadically beating
the absolute out of each other
you